welcome to CBS this morning President
Trump's plan to get tougher on
immigration will begin with a new
Secretary of Homeland Security CBS News
was first report yesterday that Kirsten
Nelson's resignation comes after less
than a year and a half in the job
the president says Customs and Border
Protection Commissioner Kevin McHale
Enon will become acting DHS secretary
now Nielsen is leaving office in the
middle of a surge of migrants at the US
border with Mexico in February alone
more than 76,000 people were arrested or
turned away at the southern border
Nielsen is now the 12th the
cabinet-level official to leave the
Trump administration in just over two
years and that is unprecedented major
Garrett is at the White House where the
timing of her exit is no coincidence
major good morning good morning senior
officials tell us Nielsen's departure is
part of a massive reorganization of
senior level management within Homeland
Security that reorganization directed
and overseen by the president's top
domestic adviser and immigration hawk
Stephen Miller Nielsen's been on the hot
seat for many months the president
almost made this move in December in
addition to the scrutiny she received
from President Trump Neilson also
received bipartisan criticism signs of
the coming shake-up at DHS emerged last
week after President Trump pulled the
nomination of Ron Vitello to be the new
leader of ice immigration and customs
enforcement Congress and the courts
created this problem in Congress alone
can fix it
announcing her resignation nielsen
tweeted I hope that the next secretary
will have the support of Congress and
the courts in fixing the laws which have
impeded our ability to fully secure
America's borders and which have
contributed to discord in our nation's
discourse Nielsen never persuaded
Congress to implement the president's
push for new immigration laws as migrant
flows increased so did the president's
frustration with Nielson before her
austere Nielson estimated 100,000
apprehensions along the southwest border
in March far larger than in previous
years
walls work
and where we have them we are blocking
illegal aliens from getting into our
country Nielsen's tenure at DHS lasted
just over 16 months before that she
briefly served as the deputy to former
White House chief of staff John Kelly
while he was at the Department of
Homeland Security part of Nielsen's
legacy implementing and defending the
president's zero-tolerance policy mass
incarceration of border crossers that
led to family separations you're talking
about 2,000 children that resulted from
their parents choosing to break the law
kevin mchale Enon who takes over for
nielsen has worked as Customs and Border
Protection Commissioner since the early
days of the Trump administration and has
called on Congress to act i briefed the
media and testified in Congress that our
immigration system was at the breaking
point that breaking point has arrived
this week at our border michaleen and
would like to get the nomination is full
homeland security secretary unclear if
that's going to happen until someone is
nominated and confirmed Mac and llenan
will join a long list of Trump
administration officials serving in an
acting capacity nielsen tweeted late
last night she will stay on officially
until Wednesday to ensure a smooth
transition other names floated Energy
Secretary Rick Perry and former acting
Attorney General Mack Whitaker to be the
new Homeland Security Secretary nominee
John all right major Garrett Thank You
major